and zach 1-0 with an era of 3.15 coming
out to the lumineers here's donovan
solano he was nine for his first 18 to
start the year but
has cooled off
back toward the middle again a slow
roller brad miller first chance of the
day throws it low and
reese hoskins holds on
and the inning is over
let's see the numbers there on diesel
fine he had a great start in miami
deserved a little bit better faith than
he got home is two for seven he did hit
a home run off of arlene garcia last
night
and it's tapped
to solano
side
retired
natan last night picked up his first
major league extra base hit
pulled to the hole on the right side of
base hit miller will hold up at second
and maitan has his third hit
now the phillies have first and second
with one out and that brings mickey
moniak to the plate
out toward left field that's well hit
dickerson's going back toward the wall
it is gone
first major league home run for mickey
moniak
an opposite field shot and the phillies
are on top
three to nothing
take it in young man take it in
all right they're gonna put the tarp on
the field this is a shame too for zach
eflin
kerwin danley
pulls everybody off
zach effluent just standing behind the
mound and that's frustrating for a
pitcher
because now you don't know depending on
how long it is if he can come back at
all right and again it'll be dictated by
the length of this storm
back at citizens bank park it's like we
never left well we didn't leave but
the rain is out of the area for the
moment the wind is still whipping
but zach f wood is back on the hill
one god here's dubois
and he lines it out to left field
mccutcheon on the run it's past him and
it's off the wall he plays it cleanly
duvan's heading to second the throw is a
little wide miller's tag he is
safe
somehow he got one of his appendages on
the bag before miller applied the tag
but the phillies will take a look at it
underneath
uh dubai is already heading off he's
heading back to the giants dugout so
much for selling it and he's out
here alec bone draws a one-out walk
and brad miller who singled through
the open hole on the left side will come
up back toward the middle crawford gets
to it will scamper to the bag ball beat
it and everybody's safe
and the phillies have first and second
with one out and here's maetone the
young shortstop who
the 2-2 pitch is
called strike three that two-seam
fastball had incredible movement
fifth inning three-nothing
phillies with buster posey standing in
announcement there's a swing buster
hooks went down the left field line
that's going to fall base hit one hop up
against the wall toward the corner
buster digging for a second here comes
the throw in from mccutcheon
too late
a sliding double for buster posey flores
bounced out the third in the second
and this is going to be off the glove
and miller's going to pick it up and
throw to first it's not in time
so posey goes to third
is
hoskins couldn't come up with it
one away and here is dubai effluent to
the plate coupon swings and drives one
into shallow right field and that's
gonna fall base hit
here comes the throw to second and
harper forces out
wilmer flores
buster posey scores but it's not a hit
for duvan it's a four sound
well solano's job is get on for
dickerson
he's bounced out twice
solano hooks it down the left field line
that's going to be a fair ball
as it bounces up against the wall
and it will allow dickerson to hit here
in the sixth
pokes at this one and flares at the left
and he's got a hit
and did solano get a chance to score he
did not i think his leg he kind of
he broke and he pulled up
pulled up lame a little bit
so what
looked like was going to be an rbi
single
solano pulls up lane
and he is being walked off the field
buster posey's one for two he doubled
his last time and scored the only run
for the giants
fly ball right fields
the wins got it harper on the track will
make the catch he's got it as well
[Applause]
it went a little farther than i think
anybody anticipated but that's the way
the wind is blowing
may todd is one for two
and the pitch swung on flare to left
that one's falling and it's going to be
in for a base hit and it squirts past
dickerson and goes all the way to the
wall miller will come home to score
maton around second he's thinking about
third the throw is offline
and the phillies now lead it four to one
it'll be a hit and an error and a
three-run lead again for the phillies
flores the hitter for the giants here's
the pitch it is driven to left field
mccutcheon
watches it and it's over his head and
off the top of the wall
mccutcheon's going to play the karum and
relay it back in wilmer's into second
crawford two for five lifetime against
skinzler with a double and a triple
floor is already on base and nobody out
the 3-1 pitch crawford hits a ground
ball toward the middle over to his right
to backhand and mayton a little bobble
his throw to first is late and offline
anyway
so crawford's safe flores goes to third
ruff has the power
to change the score with one swing
rough it's a high drive to center field
it is
out of here
and this game is tied
he comes back to philadelphia
and he unloads
it's sharply diving stop reese hoskins
flips to jojo covering in time
excellent play uh two outs here in the
seventh inning
here's yaski
shallow left field mccutcheon coming in
and he dropped it
in and out of his glove and mccutcheon
can't believe it
and yustrinski's gonna roll into second
base
well the phillies have walked longoria
and the hitter will be dickerson
and a line drive in the right center
field of bait [ __ ]
here comes jastrimski
and
the giants are going to take the lead
it's 5-4
and now two outs here in the seventh
inning and bryce harper coming up
out to right center field yustripski's
not gonna get it and it is gone
it went over the small fence a solo home
run for harper it got out of here in a
hurry and we're tied up at five well you
look for your superstar to rise to the
occasion that's what harper does to tie
this ball game up now they've got
runners in first and second with two
outs and now it's up to andrew mccutchen
the ground ball toward the shortstop
side picked up by crawford he bobbles
throws not in time everybody is safe and
the bases are loaded
and here is rhys hoskins now you got to
be careful here but no place to put him
you just got to execute he's struck him
out swinging with the high fastball
up above the belt at 92 miles an hour
and alvarez gets through it until he's
had the winning run at second base
andrew knapp is coming up
and andrew lights went into left field
to base hit harper around third heading
for home the throw by dickerson is not
in time
and the phillies win it in the bottom of
the ninth inning they win it six to five